oh wow this nights really kicking off
isn't it
so and this wonderful woman is one of
our best very best actresses of the
stage and screen and last year when yo
when Yerma
opened at the Young Vic there was this
buzz that went through London which was
unlike anything I've seen before and for
those lucky enough to get a ticket
everyone I think everyone will agree it
was the most electrifying performance
she has this rare ability to be utterly
heartbreaking and hilarious at the same
time and less hassle crying in the
toilets afterwards she has won pretty
much every accolade out there from a
Olivier tur Critics Choice Award and
she's adding this one her growing
collection this evening I did my very
first orbiter and I can say from my
heart that I have watched her with utter
admiration and love for the brave honest
action six years and for being such a
[ __ ] gorgeous person and so the award
for this year to Sado group theater
actress goes to the one and only Billy
Piper ah Lilly chair I love you okay
thank you thank you
glamour thank you Joe thank you James
who I've known since the nineties anyway
it's lovely forget that it's really
brilliant to be here tonight and receive
this award thank you readers thank you
to next your kids clothes ah oh good and
then I'd like to thank all the women in
my life
my mum you're just a [ __ ] wonder I
love you I love Harley Piper
she's my lovely little sister you're my
favorite sister
I think Ellie your cover
and yeah all the women in the room
tonight love you all and storms a you
know a woman but you are awesome thank
you guys have a lovely night Thanks